THE WAR HAS NO END IN SIGHT.
THIS HAS FORCED ORDINARY
UKRAINIAN CITIZENS TO DO EXTRA
ORDINARY THINGS IN THE NAME OF
SURVIVAL AS WE ARE NOW MANY
MONTHS INTO THE
INCOMPREHENSIBLE.
WE ARE OUT FRONT IN KHARKIV.
>> Reporter: IN A BOARDED-UP
PHARMACY IN KHARKIV, WE FOLLOW
JULIA DOWN INTO THE BASEMENT.
THEY NEVER USED THIS SPACE
BEFORE THE WAR. NOW, IT HOLDS
SHELF AFTER SHELF OF VITAL
DONATED MEDICINE WHILE ALSO
SERVING ANOTHER PURPOSE.
WE ARE DOWN HERE.
WE CAN HEAR SOME HEAVY SHELLING
FROM UP ABOVE.
THAT IS NOT VERY COMMON AT THIS
PART OF THE DAY, MID MORNING.
THANKFULLY, WE ARE ALREADY DOWN
IN THE BASEMENT, WHERE WE NEED
TO BE.
>> THAT KILLED AT LEAST SIX
CITY RESIDENTS.
>> YULIYA AND HER TEAM ARE
UNFAZED.
PREPARING TO HEAD OUT ON A
MONTHLY VISIT TO MULTIPLE
FRONTLINE VILLAGES WHICH
DESPERATELY NEED HARD TO GET
MEDICINE, MEDICAL SUPPLIES, AND
BASIC BABY FORMULA.
>> Reporter: THE PHARMACY COMES
TO THE VILLAGE, SHE SAYS.
PHARMACIES ARE EITHER DESTROYED
OR THERE ARE NO PHARMACISTS.
PEOPLE NEED MEDICINE.
THE LEAD VEHICLE IN THE CONVOY
IS AN AMBULANCE.
WHEN IT ARRIVES IN THE FIRST
VILLAGE, THE SIRENS ALREADY
RING OUT. A LINE HAS FORMED IN
THE RAIN.
ALL RETIREES, YOUNG PARENTS
WITH KIDS, ANYONE LEFT HERE
SEEMS TO COME OUT.
INCLUDING A VILLAGE DOCTOR.
WE REALLY NEED MEDICATION.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOCAL PHARMACY.
WE HAVE NOWHERE TO BUY
ANYTHING, SHE SAYS.
INSULIN, HEART, AND BLOOD
PRESSURE DRUGS ARE AT THE TOP
OF HER LAST ALONG WITH SEDATIVES
AND ANTIDEPRESSANTS.
ANIMALS ARE A PRIORITY, TOO.
ANOTHER CAR IS FULL OF DOG FOOD
FOR PETS.
THIS HONOR SAYS HER PET IS
SHELLSHOCKED FROM ALL THE
EXPLOSIONS.
THIS VILLAGE HAD BEEN OCCUPIED
BY RUSSIAN FORCES, CAUGHT
BETWEEN THE WARRING SIDES.
SCARS OF THE FIGHTING VERY
VISIBLE, AS IS THE RUSSIAN
RETREAT.
WHEN THE RUSSIANS OCCUPIED THIS
VILLAGE, A MAN WHO LIVES HERE
SAYS THAT THEY WOULD TALK THEIR
TANKS AND ARMORED VEHICLES
BETWEEN HOUSES AND COVER THEM
UP TO TRY TO HIDE THEM, BUT THE
UKRAINIANS RETOOK THE VILLAGE.
THEY BLEW UP AND DESTROYED THIS
ARMORED VEHICLE.
AFTER ABOUT AN HOUR, THE TEAM
PACKS UP AND MOVES ON TO A
POOR, RURAL VILLAGE JUST 25
KILOMETERS -- 60 MILES -- FROM
THE CLOSEST RUSSIAN POSITION.
THE RESIDENTS GATHER AROUND
EVEN FASTER. THE PROFOUND NEED
FOR AID IS CLEAR.
WHILE WE ARE THERE, A TEAM FROM
WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN ARRIVES
TO HAND OUT MEALS.
ANOTHER EAGER LINE FORMS.
>> [ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]
>> Reporter: MANY OF THE
UKRAINIANS WE MET WERE FORCED
TO LIVE IN THE BASEMENTS OF
THEIR OWN HOMES WHILE RUSSIANS
OCCUPIED THEM.
YULIYA TELLS US THEY ARE
HELPLESS, HE